let's talk about Bloom filters not to be
confused with the bloom Shader effect a
bloom filter is a simple probabilistic
set originally conceived by Burton
Bloom yeah it's not some weird
mathematical Bloom it's just his last
name suppose you run a website where
users post links 99% are cat pictures
cool new websites and YouTube videos but
every once in a while someone posts a
link to a known malicious site which you
want to block there's millions of known
bad links so you pay for a service that
keeps a list of them that you can query
calling out to the service costs money
and slows down your response times to
your users so you'd really like to know
whether a link is bad without quering
the service but with say 10 million bad
links and considering overhead it could
easily take a gig of extra Ram if you
just stored all the data in a python set
with a bloom filter we could cut down on
98% of calls to the service using only
10 megabytes of extra
memory but before we see how a bloom
filter can help your website first
you're going to need a website so please
consider consider this video sponsor
hostinger for all your web hosting needs
hostinger just happens to be running
their biggest ever Black Friday sale
where you can get their business plan
for as little as $3.49 a month if you
just want a tinker there's also the
Premium plan which goes as low as $199 a
month and comes with everything you need
to get started like a free domain email
and SSL
certificates but if you want to run a
site with some real traffic I recommend
the business plan which additionally
comes with increased performance and
access to hostinger CDN
when you check out make sure to use
coupon code M coding to get an
additional 10% off on top of the Black
Friday
deals choose your free domain and use
the website builder if you're a novice
or deploy your site straight from GitHub
if you're a pro and don't forget to use
my custom link in the description to let
them know that I sent you let's get back
to bloom filters a bloom filter is kind
of like a set and that you can add
things to it and it quickly tells you
whether an element is in the set except
when you ask if an element is in the set
it either tells you possi yes or
definitely no in other words if it tells
you no the element is 100% not in the
set but if it tells you yes there's a
small chance the answer is actually no
oh yeah and you can't remove elements
from a bloom filter either if you need
to remove something you need to create a
whole new one from scratch you're
probably thinking this sounds like a
worst version of a set why would I ever
want a data structure that has a
restricted interface and gives me
incorrect results like many
probabilistic data structures the answer
is that by giving up a bit in accuracy
and flexibility we can save an enormous
amount in performance the catch is that
you need a use case where mistakenly
identifying an element as in the set
when it's not is okay that often occurs
when you have a fast way to compute
something that works for most but not
all elements and a much more expensive
way to compute the same thing that
always works for our website we can use
a bloom filter to tell us yes a link is
possibly bad or definitely no this link
is not a known bad link if the bloom
filter says a link is possibly bad we
fall back to the paid service to give us
a reliable answer so it's fine if we get
a false positive in a small percentage
of cases that's still a win compared to
sending everything to the paid
service great so how does a bloom filter
work think about identifying objects by
their Shadows Shadows contain much less
data than the originals but given an
object you can usually tell whether it's
part of a shadow yes the Shadows could
conspire to trick you into seeing
something that isn't there but in
reasonable cases you can work around it
a bloom filter can of a block of memory
that's M bits long along with some
number K of hash functions in order to
add an item to the set we hash it using
each hash function and set the bit at
the corresponding memory location to
one this pattern of bits from the hash
functions is like the object's
Shadow then to query we an elements in
the set we look for its shadow by using
each hash function and checking whether
all the corresponding bits are set if
any bit is a zero then this item was
definitely not added to the set if every
bit's a one it's either because the
element is actually in the set or
because some combination of other
elements happen to set those bits so we
can at best say the element is possibly
in the set that's really all there is to
the bloom filter it uses a fixed amount
of memory no matter how many elements
you add and the time it takes to add or
query elements only depends on how many
and how slow your hash functions are not
how many elements were added already its
implementation is rather simple we'll
get to that later all the difficulty
lies in analyzing how much memory and
how many hash functions to use if we use
M bits of memory K hash functions and
added n items what's the chance of
falsely identifying an element as in the
set when actually it's not in real life
it depends measure it but we can get a
good approximate answer if we assume the
hash functions select bits uniformly and
independently for distinct
elements for a fixed bit the chance that
one hash of a single element will set
that bit is 1 M so the chance that the
bit is not set is 1 minus that for K
independent hash functions to all not
set that bit we raise that to the power
K and repeating this for n total
elements we raise that to the power
n this is the chance that this fixed bit
is not set after adding n elements
therefore the chance this fixed bit is
set after adding n elements is 1 minus
that and a false positive means that K
fixed bits have all been set so we raise
that to the power K to finally arrive at
our estimate of the false positive rate
you can start plugging in numbers if you
want or using calculus we can
approximate this as follows multiply and
divide by
m and then use the limit definition of
e and then
rearrange notice the quantity m/n is
something meaningful to us that's how
many bits of storage we've allocated per
element if we fix that quantity to say 1
BTE per element and plot we see that we
don't need a huge number of hash
functions in fact the error rate is
minimized using around 5 hash functions
more generally using calculus take
derivatives set to zero Etc you can show
that we can achieve an error rate as
small as we like by choosing the number
of hash functions to be about log base 2
of the desired error rate and the number
of bits per element to be about 1.44
times that so if we're okay with around
a 2% false positive rate then we could
use five or six hash functions and eight
bits per element for 10 million elements
that's just 10 megab of data regardless
of how large each element is because the
filter doesn't store the actual
elements okay but where can I get K
different hash functions for my data
instead of inventing a bunch of hash
functions there are a few tricks you can
do like using a hash function that takes
a seed or appending k different suffixes
to your data before hashing but here's a
trick that can get the job done using
just one good hash
function if I'm using 10 megab of memory
that's 80 million bits so my hash
functions need to Output numbers up to
80 million higher is fine we'll just mod
by the length but we need at least up to
80 million log base 2 of 80 million is
26.25 so my hashes really only need to
be 27 bits long how about I use a 256bit
hash and then just split the first 2 40
bits into five chunks of 48 bits treat
each chunk as a separate hash function
and now I've got five 48-bit hash
functions that I can use for my Bloom
filter obviously if you need many more
hash functions there won't be enough
bits and this trick won't work but for
our use case it does work
now let's implement it it's super simple
this is the whole
implementation we take in the memory and
a function that computes the hashes I
chose to use a function that outputs
multiple hashes rather than to store a
list of hash functions because hashes
may share computation like first
Computing the 256-bit hash then
splitting that into 5 48-bit chunks
there's no need to recompute the 256-bit
hash five
times estimating the false positive rate
is just plugging into the formula we had
earlier in the video
adding an element means calculating each
hash and setting the corresponding bit
to
one and checking if an element is in the
set means calculating each hash and
checking whether any of the
corresponding bits are not
set here we see how to split the output
of a hash function into smaller ones
which is pretty
straightforward the last gotcha we need
to work around is that in Python if we
use a list of integers as our underlying
memory for the bloom filter that's going
to be using a bytes per index because
under the hood python will store a
pointer to the unique cached Z or one
int object at each index location that's
64 times more memory than the one bit
per index we assumed in our analysis
therefore to really make use of a bloom
filter we should use something like a
bit array that uses one bit per
index we can Implement a bit array like
this have it hold the data which is made
of an array of btes and a size we keep
track of the size separately because we
might want to store a number of bits
bits that's not a multiple of eight so
the array might be a few bits longer
than the size we can construct an array
of zeros like this allocating a bite for
every eight bits round it up getting a
bit is just calculating which bite and
which bit within the bite using div mod
then grabbing that index and masking out
the bit we
want setting a bit is similar this first
expression we do a bitwise and to clear
the bit then the second one we do a bit
wise or to set the value we
want
putting it all together we can use it
like this we Define a hash function in
this case we just use shot 256 and
convert the result to an INT we split
our long hash into five hashes that use
6 bytes or 48 bits each then we create
our storage as a bit array initialize to
zeros and create the bloom filter I made
a little timer utility here that just
times each operation not important we
create 10 million random length 16
strings and add them to the bloom filter
note that we're using a huge amount of
memory here because we continue to store
the strings in memory for the malicious
link detection use case we could add all
the links to the bloom filter and then
serialize just the bloom filter to
distribute to our servers the servers
don't need to keep all the individual
links so they would only need that extra
10 megabytes of memory for the bloom
filter not gigabytes for all the
strings just to check our implementation
we assert that there are no false
negatives meaning that everything that
we did add returns true when we check
whether it's there then we count false
positives by querying an equal number of
strings that were not added to the
filter and compare with the estimated
false positive rate based off our
mathematical
analysis amazingly we find a 2.1 169
false positive rate which is stunningly
close to the estimated 2.68%
estimate everything was completely
random and yet we predicted the answer
with great Precision probability is
pretty
cool anyway you probably noticed these
times are really long which is caused by
the fact that we're committing the
cardinal sin of doing a numerical hot
Loop in Python for 10 million
iterations this won't really be an issue
in production since you're going to be
bottlenecked by waiting on the network
way before this makes any difference but
if you really want to I'm sure you could
find a decent C extension that
implements a bloom filter my name is
James Murphy my company is M coding and
we do software Consulting and once again
thank you to this video sponsor
hostinger don't forget to check out
their current sale and use coupon code M
coding at checkout you can use my
personalized Link in the description
also thanks to my patrons and donors see
you in the next one